when you do a written budget on paper on
purpose every dollar has an assignment
before the month begins and you're in
agreement with your spouse on that and
that is not a theory it is the directive
for your month you live according to the
numbers that you write down you do not
spend anything except what is written
down without coming back and adjusting
the budget when you do that you will add
a layer of communication to your
marriage that will change your marriage
in a good way when you do that you will
get the stress off of your back because
not knowing if anything is getting done
will drive you crazy if you can do
everything but three things you got all
the stress off your back but three
things you limit the stress to the
things you simply don't have the money
to get to this month if you're broken
struggling in under water a written
budget when you will lay it out and
stick to it will give you the sense that
you have gotten a raise it feels like
you got a raise because your money is so
stinking out of control when it's not in
control I know that's insightful you can
tweet that your money's not it's not in
control when it's not in control I mean
really that's the truth though it sounds
so basic but if you do not have a clear
written plan that you and your spouse
have a pinky swear and spit shake it's a
dadgum contract we're going to stick to
it you don't have that you're just
you're just hoping is all you're doing
you're not planning you're hoping if you
worked for a company and you manage
money for that company and the company
was called you incorporated and you
managed money for you incorporated like
you managed money for you now would you
fire you don't answer that
well then don't be praying and asking
God to send you financial blessings when
you're misbehaving with the little that
you do have when you're faithful with
the little things you'll be given more
to manage write it out go to every
dollar calm get your iPhone out get the
free app out it's a free online
budgeting tool in ten minutes you'll
have a budget write it out Zig Ziglar
used to say if you aim at nothing you'll
hit it every single time John Maxwell
says a budget is people telling their
money what to do instead of wondering
where it went
write it out write it down your stress
is lowered your communication and the
quality of communication with your
spouse is increased your efficiency is
up to the point that you will feel like
you got a raise you will make progress
when you do this because even if you
write it all down and you don't have
enough to do everything immediately what
do you start doing it going I got to get
some income I got a amputate some crap
out of my life so that this thing
balances because you know if your budget
doesn't balance you have to fix it
because you know you're not in Congress
you know you have to do it
I mean inherently if you graduated from
the sixth grade you can do this it's
addition and subtraction probably the
fourth grade but you have to write it
down and you have to look the beast in
the face and say Beast you're getting a
haircut Beast we're going to pull a
couple of your fangs here Beast you're
going to get under control I'm tired of
you managing me I'm going to manage you
the money beast will put its foot on
your neck and hold you down your whole
life until you stand up and say I've had
enough on paper on purpose when you do a
budget it's a whip and a chair you're
the lion tamer
you're making that money dance you're
making that money behave you're making
it do what it's supposed to do when you
do this you will find the money to hit
baby step one and quickly save $1,000
and then to start working your debt
snowball baby step two listing your
debts
smallest to largest everything but the
house paying minimum payments on
everything but the little one and you
are attacking the little one with a
vengeance mad I've had it I work too
hard to be this broke I am sick and
tired of making a hundred and one
thousand dollars a year and getting
nowhere you have to have that thing come
up inside of you
it comes up inside of you it changes
your life and then you have to have a
clear path to run on and that starts
with the budget and the excess you
squeeze out of the budget from
increasing your income and decreasing
your outgo by cutting back on things
like not seeing the inside of a
restaurant unless you own it or you work
there and don't talk to me about going
on vacation you're broke broke people
don't go on vacation you lay out the
game plan and you get an attack mode
beans and rice rice and beans scorched
earth the formula is the deeper you
sacrifice the more money is freed up in
the faster you get out of the mess and
the faster you get into the prosperity
so that your life is changed and you're
in a position to be outrageously
generous your generosity factor
increases as soon as you get control as
soon as you get they get the beast off
of you but it's hard to be generous when
you're worried about your own electric
bill being paid it's hard to be generous
when you don't know if you've got the
money for food it's hard to be generous
in those situations a written budget
jesus said don't build a tower without
first counting the cost lets you get a
halfway up and you're unable to finish
and all who see you begin to mock you
and say this man began to build and was
unable to finish on paper on purpose or
get on every dollar calm and use the
free that I mentioned it's free online
budget tool click on the iPhone apps and
get the free iPhone app and you can tell
your money what to do you can become a
money's intimidating to me well that's
because it kicks your butt it's time for
your
kick its butt it's time for you to stand
up say that's it I'm not living like
this anymore I'm going to get control of
my dad blame life I'm sick of walking
around with this taste of regret in my
mouth feeling like I'm a financial fool
I'm sick of that and when you get sick
of that you can change the taste in your
mouth because you can do the math math
bothers me it's not hard math this is
not rocket surgery baby it's not hard
you can do it but you have to let me
just tell you I hear all the theories I
hear old people talk about it I've read
some of the dumb butt blogs that are
written out there about money and some
of these people living in their mother's
basement they should not be allowed to
have an opinion in public okay seriously
this stuff's stupid I've been doing this
25 years I've helped millions tens of
millions of people get out of debt and
the way you do it is a written plan
there is no exception you cannot out
earn your disorganization and stupidity
I've got 14 profit centers in our
company you think a VP walks into my
office and says you know Dave this
quarter I'm going to kind of wing it
we're not going to really do our revenue
and our expense and our profit
projections this quarter how you think
that would work in my office if you work
for a company and your job was to manage
money for that company and you walked in
and said you know I'm just kind of kind
of kind of think I know what it's doing
I'm gonna be okay you think they
wouldn't fire your little butt of course
they'd fire your little butt and you'd
be deserving of a good firing cuz you be
incompetent and you know that the good
news about being incompetent in
something as simple as a budget is you
can just decide today tada
today I'm gonna start being competent
you just decided just like that it takes
10 minutes on every dollar lay this
thing out there is no freaking excuse
for you to be walking around with regret
on the back of your tongue waking up
with a financial hangover
during all your dadgum money went it's
you gotta stop it gotta stop it we give
you all the tools to do it
free sit down do your written plan get
your spouse on board start aiming at
something intentionally that make the
sacrifices to go win you can win people
do it every day but you're gonna have to
get with it you have to turn up the gas
baby turn up the heat this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey you guys Rachael Cruz
here hope you are enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show and did you know that I have
my very own YouTube channel yes that's
right it's kind of better than the Dave
Ramsey channel don't tell them I said
that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
check out how to do a monthly budget
it's one of the best videos out there
you